Speaker 1: I have for you today some this
is probably my favorite video from the last
three months other than my own interview with
Mike Pelo, Mike Lyndell, the CEO of My Pillow.
This is a fantastic interview from Australia where
Sarah Ferguson interviews Sydney Powell. Now,
Sydney Powell was one of the lawyers going
around the country trying to legislate Trump's
voter fraud claims at different points in time.
Sydney Powell was at one point in the Oval Office
meeting with Trump, at another point denounced
or not denounced, but disassociated from Trump,
claiming this is not someone working for
me. This is someone doing her own thing.
This interview is like nothing I have ever
seen. At one point, Sydney Powell just cuts
the interview. Let's take a look at some of the
highlights. Listen to this. And what's the point
here? The point I know some people say, David,
don't tell us what the point is. Let us watch it.
Look at how when we go full circle, these people
who were adamant about their claims when they
were carrying out these legal challenges. Now you
can tell they never knew what the hell they were
talking about. Let's take a listen. Look at this.
Speaker 3: Let's get a few simple facts straight.
Yes. How many states were Smartmatic machines
and software used in the twenty twenty election?
I don't even know the exact numbers, but you
were making some big statements, very dramatic,
critical statements about Smartmatic. You
must have known what their involvement was
in the election. No, you'd have to go look at our
complaint against with respect to the four states
that we file legal complaints. And to get the
details of that, a Google search would have shown
you that Smartmatic was operating in one single
county in California. I'm saying I think their
involvement is probably a lot bigger than that.
Speaker 1: OK, so now you start to see Sydney
Powell doesn't even really know the involvement
of Smartmatic, which was like the centerpiece
of her claims and without evidence, even after
being told the facts about Smartmatic, she just
I just believe they were more involved.
Oh, OK. And is that the type of argument
you would expect to make in court?
Speaker 3: Sydney Researchable fact
checking, did you do at the time to find out what
Smartmatic actual involvement in the election was?
Do you work for Smartmatic? You made an
allegation against Smartmatic that they stole?
Speaker 1: No, I'm a journalist. I'm
wondering whether you have any basis
for the claims you make presidential election.
Speaker 3: I think it's incumbent on both of
us to know what Smartmatic involvement was.
It seems like a pretty foundational fact.
I mean, I'm confused right
now about why you're here,
because you may. How did you get
Speaker 1: into my house, ma'am,
who let you in a series
Speaker 3: of very strong
allegations against Smartmatic and against
Dominion containing. Many errors of fact,
do you accept the fact now that the company
that you accused of stealing a national
election only operated in one county in L.A., in
California? No. One county, one state? No, I'm not
prepared to accept that fact. I think Smartmatic
involvement was far more significant than that,
too. I think they are trying to minimize
their involvement. Of course I do. You said
that Smartmatic owns Dominion. How do you justify
such a basic factual error? I'm going to stop this
interview. Right. It's wholly inappropriate. And
the litigation that we're in, we're not even in
the area of great dispute. These are the simple
facts of who owns what we're done. All right.
So she gets the facts when we're in
litigation against me personally.
I understand that. But we're billions. Yes,
I understand that. These are very serious
allegations. Very much. But these are also so
Speaker 1: as you can tell, absolutely no factual
basis for anything. She does eventually
come back, although it seems almost like
under protest. Let's take a look at a little more.
Speaker 3: After some discussion, Miss Powell
agreed to answer more questions. Yeah, I'm highly
skeptical of how long this is going to last,
claiming her legal issues prevented her from
talking about the voting machine companies.
All of the organizations who had the
responsibility to check the nature of this
election and to verify its results say there was
no fraud. That's the propaganda they're putting
out. I disagree with that completely. And we have
and will produce additional evidence that shows.
Speaker 1: Otherwise, how many years will it take
to produce the evidence they claim is coming?
I mean, I'm not asking it sarcastically. I would
I would love to know from them. Do you think we
will get this in 22, 23, 28? When will we get that
evidence? Trump says very soon. Very, very soon.
Speaker 3: What you're describing is a massive
countrywide fraud involving the FBI, the DOJ, the
Department of Homeland Security, the organizations
who certify elections and on and on all the way
up to the attorney general and thousands of local
election officials. Are you saying that thousands
of Americans participated in a fraud? I am saying
that thousands of Americans had some role in it,
knowingly or unknowingly. It was essentially
a bloodless coup where they took over the
presidency of the United States without a single
shot being fired. Who's they in that sentence?
I don't know who all the they are. They did it.
Speaker 1: I don't know who they are. They didn't
even know they were doing it, but they did it.
Speaker 3: I would really like to know the
answer to that, but it's a significant number of
they and they knew exactly what they were doing
and they planned it for at least three years.
This was no accident. Do you ever hear yourself
and think that it sounds ridiculous? I
know I know myself very well. I've been
in me a long time.
Speaker 1: She has
been inside of herself long enough to know.
She sounds totally normal, my friend. So,
you know, is Sidney Powell delusional? Is there a
mental illness component here? Is she just wrong?
Is there a financial incentive? I don't I don't
think there is a financial incentive. I ask that,
but I am pretty sure the answer. There is no what
on earth is going on with this woman? And that is
just stunning. Stunning video. We'll have more
of those clips on the show's Instagram. You can
find us on Instagram The David Pakman Show. And
while you're there, follow me at David Pakman.